a imprensa a cura e aí galera que
assiste meu canal tudo bom com vocês
essa música que eu entrei cantando
adolei wind vocês me pergunta quando é
que sai o alvo do luigi quando é que sai
o áudio linha de mas eu não sou eu
ingrid ou se você quiser perguntar para
ele lá no instagram dele e pergunte a
ele siga ele se você tiver aqui depois
de vários anos só porque isso aqui é
vídeo de [ __ ] porque quando é assim o
dia que eu assisti o xvídeo pornô aí dá
não sei quantos milhões de visualizações
agora eu gravar o vídeo indo para a
igreja vamos orar aí da tem mil
visualizações a de macedo silas malafaia
tom 70 fico como tem gente tá aqui
depois de anos eu vou fazer propaganda
mesmo das coisas que tem no meu canal
tudo que o canal relevo tal então tá
então tem paródia daquele programa
largados e pelados é só ficando na selva
eu fiz uma paródia uma hora aí todinha
do trabalho está portão assistir então
tem meu show no netflix adulta só
pesquisar tão tão documentário mostrando
o bastidor da minha vida que você nunca
vira
e como é que eu falo a minha vida que eu
faço onde ele anda o que ele comprei ele
come só aqui no youtube só aqui no
youtube é o documentário de uma hora de
ou não deixa que assistir um
documentário feito por mim mesmo tá
muito engraçado e tem muitas dicas para
você aqui quer alcançar o sucesso é
deixar enrolar não se você quer saber na
portaria eu assisti aquele filme 365
dias só para falar para vocês que eu
tinha visto a repercussão no twitter mas
só que era muito 80 assim era muito
dividida assim então mulher meu deus do
céu você viu como ele pegou ele não só
foi tão gostosinho aí a outra depois de
dar um tapa na cara dela enforcada eu
lembro assim pensando curioso eu fui
assistir aquela assistir para botar para
você então já clica logo em gostei aí
você acerta direitinho tire as crianças
de perto acho que tá comendo que você
não é meu amigo hoje em dia o menino
danado a criança acorda 5 horas da manhã
pega o tablet é da nha da linha para
botar na galinha pintadinha ela mesmo
digita a criança fala balinha e escreve
galinha como é que pode
e mais o enfim aí deu play lá no filme
na netflix inclusive a mesma plataforma
que está o meu show adulto lá na netflix
é bastante lá sério mesmo não já vai
começar já vamos fazer o seguinte junto
só combinar todo mundo dá o play no meu
show de led vídeos agora vai lá na sala
na netflix bota televisão dá o play
deixa lá alguém assistindo e vem aqui
assistir o vídeo não só para mim coisar
lá para ajudar me ajuda me ajuda então
tá combinado te prometeu vai botar
propaganda mesmo tá não é meu aí eu dei
o play-doh no filme começou tá eu sinto
começando os créditos já começa a ficar
imaginando o filme de [ __ ] eu sempre
pensando cara quem foi que gostou meu
quarto é isso que eu tenho que ser
bilionário de filme e esse essa estrada
dele sair mais o quarto ela tá ali
quando ele chega já fizeram que nós tem
que voltar
e o a mãe para aparecer é isso hoje eu
não sei o valor hoje eu fiquei pensando
que é que ele ficava pensa quando eu
pegar aquela pilantra ele bateu o nível
errado aqui aí meu amigo amanhã fica
torta vou então se fosse alguém que não
tivesse um braço aqui não sei pode ser
também mas até bom essa sensibilidade né
porque todo mundo tem o direito sexual
amarrado coisa até peixes mesmo eu tenho
deficiente físico sonho é ir na praia
com certeza tenho que de assim pode
praia meu irmão meu negócio é fazer amor
violento me amarra só quer ser sufocado
e levar a rosada eu tem a imaginação
fértil viu nany bem imagina os pedreiros
que fizeram o negócio da casa que está
grávida e
e começa no castelo aqueles do rerd né
do harry potter lá na casa do carai para
lá no lugar que só chega que é o dono
mesmo quem é visita nem já está em cima
do castelo lá então negociando um com o
outro lá pois é meu irmão comprando sei
o que você fica comprando que meu irmão
que que ele tá vendendo aí tá falando
baixinho em cima de um castelo perigoso
a pessoa em cima de castela conhece o
castelo é como nós que se for no castelo
vai ficar eita legal tu é doido sai
daqui de cima tá bolsa eu pensava que a
gente tem toda vez que ele vai no lugar
alto a gente fica aí tem caído aqui em
cima cardoso claro meu irmão cai da cama
acabou se bateu pouco sabe que ele está
negociando dreams menina de 12 anos diga
aí como é que vai ser o filme leve alves
ator principal tá lá olhando o negócio
lá embaixo o máximo que ele tem uma voz
sexy mas ninguém me leva a sério falei
aí como é que você tá bom tá tranquilo a
pessoa que eu não posso certo falando
sério queria só conversar um pouco e
o teste deixe ela só quer ir aparecer
marginal e aí beleza oferecendo às
crianças e aí beleza oferecer às
crianças aqui meu deus que pariu maria
maria maria vai falar da felicidade a
família do máximos não curte criança a
família do carro não vai faz tudo do
mundo para criança na coisa de perguntar
o limite do morro né se perguntar para
ele para o qual o limite do traficante
criança hiato tarde aí não tem aquela
fumaça os parado né sendo bonito que
está bonitão fala a verdade unir o carro
minha rapaz tem que ir meu amigo deixa
de ser besta é ei ei rapaz rapaz rapaz é
bonito não é presença é bonito vocês
perde o lado bom da vida porque vai lá
na foto do amigo de vocês presença é
você deixa de elogiar o seu amigo dentro
como é que tá lá poxa brother de bombom
na massa em tamo junto irmão são que
amigo bota soltinho na foto né como se
tivesse sido feita essa rádio online
você como sempre é um rio aqui ó tudo
direitinho mad brother velho
e nada outras coisas poxa você só tá
dizer assunto aqui de tanto que o cabelo
bonito ele vai conversar com o pai dele
é o pai dele fala meu filho isso aqui é
um dia tudo se fala meu pai dele matar o
velho na minha frente fangs palhaço tira
atravessa pega no mato nos barreiros não
morre porque ele é máximo velho quer vir
agora o máximo meu filho dele mesmo e lá
pago de um tiro viu travesti não ficou
no ouro e no na minha sala sujou tudo e
esqueci de botar beterraba no prato
leopoldo cara na minha comida aí beleza
aí beleza acabou de maud morreu o pai aí
beleza o meu deus mas é porque é bom
fazer a vírgula assim aí beleza aí tá lá
né aí beleza mas penso que não beleza
beleza vou até tu está aí se você não
esteja no meu twitter está aí na tela
para você me seguir a desgraçada da
pessoa até aí tudo bem vai história que
a pessoa contou tem 15 minutos na
história dela caiu gente demora aí eu
igual perder o dinheiro do rapaz de tudo
traz que a pessoa até aí tudo bem meu
deus do céu tomar um tipo só um bocado
mas ok enfim até aí tudo bem aí beleza
porta para 5 ano depois já passar
e parece que o negócio da empresa do
máximos começar a da merda porque não tá
legal não tá bacana e paralelo a essa
cena tem uma cena dá uma mulher do filme
principal perdeu merda lá na empresa que
ela tava trabalhando eu sou duas cenas
em paralelo que fica cortando de uma
para outra do máximo que deu merda na
empresa do mato nos da empresa aquela lá
do trabalho para a maior [ __ ] chamar
ela para conversar lá disse que [ __ ] é
essa que está acontecendo aqui é o mais
fala meu irmão não quero saber eu quero
tanto e tal dia a outra cara zangado né
porque não sei que você investiu e
investiu foi você que investir arrumar
meu irmão eu não quero saber não foi
você que falou para fazer crescimento
então a culpa é sua ana laura tá na mesa
tem um monte de homem na mesa onde você
quer ir para reclamando com ela para
carai porque perder dinheiro cabo assim
de terno dos cabelo sábio homem de
cabelo lambido que perde dinheiro fica
insuportável acabaram certeza ele tem
capacidade outra fechou com a minha [ __ ]
né nós é homem [ __ ] normanda [ __ ]
assim um ambiente de trabalho
sensacional tava perceber que é baixinha
assim mas parece ele entrou com um metro
e oitenta e cinco
o código estresse ódio é conhecido isso
eu não falei com o que ela trabalha e
você já sabe como é que é a situação aí
volta parceira do máximo cava play bota
o contrato bora meu irmão acima aí vai
começando a falar com todo mundo aí fala
com a mulher fala assim tá vendo que
essa família aqui ela trabalha com esse
banco é muito tempo em por favor esqueci
banco deve minha família agora você vai
começa a falar com a mulher ou de várias
victor uma mulher e agora deve tá geando
o que que seus filhos diria começa a
humilhar a mulher na frente do ambiente
de trabalho havendo é assim que os
otários babacas vivem humilhando as
pessoas por causa dele tá na hora das
pessoas parar de humilhar os outros por
causa de seco porque não dormi abraçado
e dizer que sabe que ela queria transar
porque a vida tá um lixo porque não
depois de arrebitado e um lado da bunda
um dormir abraçado uma água às vezes
tomar um banho tá como diz o ditado quem
toma banho come duas vezes às vezes
deixar a senhora do banco se sentir mais
bonita mas não o cara olha perto da
mulher diz assim quer que seus filhos
vão achar o mapa
a [ __ ] sexy chega a mesma frase [ __ ]
não dá o meu irmão meu pai não gostei
coisa feia rapaz cabra bonito mas como
os outros milho é beleza clima de
romance ela sai da empresa ele sai do
trabalho pela música sexy já para entrar
no clima né o ovo e eu liguei agora
papai vamos vamos vamos vamos aqui para
dar aquele clima de solidão sabe aí
nossas sólidos ela vai saindo da sala do
ambiente de trabalho a saltar vazia todo
mundo já saiu dá para ver na cara dela
assim como se o pensamento tivesse
saindo dizendo assim eu só queria dar e
dormir galera do carro lá no decote mas
vou fazer um videozinho lá mandar para o
namorado ela faz um vídeo assim todo
delicado né eu acho massa nude de mulher
tanto delicado tem um mistérios um homem
não vamos ao peraí tá é minha filha ver
materna a de baixo para cima na papada
tão nem aí e aí minha filha o máximo uma
hora dessa já tá dentro do carro ainda
passou a casa de ele recebe um vídeo da
gatinha ou no dia gatinha fazendo assim
mas é outra mulher mostrando para ele
bloquear tela assim como que diz assim
ai meu deus as meninas só querem sexo
afe aí ela chega em casa vai no
já tá chegando ele é o marido da minha
filha deixa eu terminar de escutar aqui
rapaz não vão viajar amanhã cadê a malu
tá arrumado máximo já está navio eles
estão olhando para a cara do aeromoça
passa para arrumar um negócio ali dentro
de ouvir o cara levanta minha amiga
igual sniper passa fecha as cortinas
olha ela ele olha a mulher oi dele para
ela para ela está dizendo assim minha
filha conhece lareira que você vai levar
ela aí e a minha filha torta palavra já
pegou o vibrador aqui ó dentro do quarto
a rota para avião no máximo aeromoça
esse olhar não deu 10 segundos acaba tá
com a pomba na goela dela meu amigo eu
passei o filme todinho com medo de olhar
nos olhos dele ave maria mulher passada
e a laura lá no quarto só em é o marido
dela da sala pai do cortando a grama ali
dentro do quarto é isso avião e meu
amigo tira da boca nem para tomar um
copo d'água a porta lá ela quer sendo na
masturbação feminina é porque ela sabe
onde é o cli
um ponto baixo passam aqui na laura
volta parceiro do máximo e tome pomba na
agulha desta mulher e eu tentando ver a
rola dele não conseguia ter filme que
não é pornô e tem cena de sexo eu fico
tentando ver o pau do carro não adianta
não sei o que é isso eu não sei o que é
isso havendo já vou começar a
especulação aí só porque eu falei isso é
meu amigo é de brom e cara qual é o
problema se eu posso para ver de mim
mesmo quando estamos assistindo o filme
de galera eu sou a pessoa que podem
falar o pau dele hahaha eu não conseguia
ver e colocava passando a dela contaram
mas eles o cabo cortar eu comecei a
perceber que tava dependendo da gozar da
laura para essa cena que acabar lá tava
fazer minha filha termino logo aí que o
rapaz vai matar havia lei aqui dentro do
avião ela terminou graças a deus o rapaz
liberou a moça para tomar um gatorade o
assunto e se não dá até uma hora aí a
laura e o marido dela viagem né para o
negócio lá no máximo 10 do avião é feliz
loja aí o marido dela tá sendo otária
ali no aniversário dela fica fazendo
vergonha mas o vestido velho de short
o chinelo brasil usa feia rapaz cara
chato eu sou legal só desarrumado mas eu
sou legal eu chego no lugar 30 segundos
depois que eu falo as minhas vestes são
detalhes um cara desse 40 anos foram-se
perdendo o menino tá ruim ele puxa
parabéns para ela mas não dele é mara
tem novo faz vergonha que só o carai ela
sai para tomar um vento quando olhei
para trás tem que instalar ela vira para
o lado vira para o outro mil corta para
de dias já tá tomando sol tá falando
seus maridos até que pano com outra aí
foi para otários aqui ele chega tinha
feito um passeio não tinha convidado ela
no dia do aniversário dela ela ficou
ponta meu jovem ela empurrou e na água
desligou duro adulto se afogando em
piscina de criança é meu deus música
drástica rama ela sai correndo nas ruas
indefesas machistas ruas cheias de
malfeitores que todo mundo brincando na
verdade mesmo andou na rua ou eu fiquei
com uma frito com ela andando eu vou
escuro rapaz o cara na frente dela tá
perdida quando ela acorda ela está numa
cama uma cama bonita numa casa bonita
com banheiro bonito de bebê que as
um banho peladas nuas à frente umas às
outras normais ela levanta vai na porta
tenta abrir 30 ela olha aquele quarto
bonito de rico de monção e quem sabe o
deus será que eu fui sequestrada pelos
carolina foi embaixador que o que
acontece depois daí isso você só vai
saber na parte 2 desse vídeo mas não
fica muito grande então clique em gostei
aí e comenta aqui embaixo eu não se
esquece de se inscrever no canal se você
não é inscrito ou se você gostou até
aqui clique em gostei tá quero que você
comente aqui embaixo o que que você
achou desse vídeo eu tô participando das
votações na internet que quando você me
ajudar a votar eu fiz um jeito muito
mais fácil fique sem um tweet lá no meu
twitter é só chegar lá e dá rt cada rt é
um voto você usar a hashtag nos seus
tweets é mais votos link aqui na
descrição do vídeo tá bom tamo junto é
nóis valeu e fui